this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer Tesla has grown
rapidly over the past decade when it
became the first American automotive
company to go public since Ford in 1956
the attraction towards Tesla is
undeniable their cars are slick their
acceleration is insane and perhaps most
importantly their brand represents a
movement towards renewable energy Tesla
has attracted thousands of
well-intentioned people who want to play
their part in saving the world but there
have been niggling questions on the
minds of many Eevee owners and Eevee
naysayers when is that expensive battery
going to need to be replaced and at what
cost as existing Tesla's begin to age
and more exotic and demanding models of
Tesla's come to the fore like the Tesla
truck and roadster - these issues are
going to become more prominent these
batteries do not come cheap but they are
getting cheaper this chart shows the
cost per kilowatt hour for Tesla's power
packs and the market average boat
dropping dramatically as technologies
advanced and manufacturing volumes
increased but that storage capacity
slowly creeps away as the battery is
used slowly degrading the range of your
electric vehicle Tesla currently offers
a warranty to all model 3 owners that
covered below 8 years or 160 thousand
kilometers whichever comes first
guaranteeing a retention of capacity of
at least 70% when used under normal use
if it falls below that they will replace
your battery for free finding out what
is considered normal use is pretty
difficult but they seem to be reasonable
with it going by customer satisfaction
reports from our graph earlier it's
estimated that Tesla is achieving a cost
of 150 dollars per kilowatt hour of
battery packs so the 50 kilowatt hour
battery pack of the base model would
cost around $7,500 to replace so they
must be pretty confident on those
numbers as a massive recall of the
approximately 193,000 model 3 is
currently shipped Woodrum
Tesla ultimately these batteries are
unlikely to drop below the warranties
guarantee in those 160,000 kilometers
but even so improving batteries is
obviously just a wise business decision
to retain those customers in future this
is just one of a myriad of factors that
influence Tesla's recent landmark
acquisition of Maxwell technologies for
two hundred and eighteen million dollars
a rare Tesla acquisition that sets Tesla
up for not just cheaper batteries but
better batteries that will be lighter
have greater range and live a longer
life it wouldn't be the first time an
automotive company underestimated their
battery degradation when the Nissan Leaf
debuted in 2010 the battery production
they needed simply did not exist and
neither did the technical expertise
required to design battery packs in
those days lithium-ion batteries cost
about $400 per kilowatt hour for laptop
grade batteries and up to $1,000 per
kilowatt hour for the ones with the
longevity needed for an electric vehicle
to minimize cost Nissan decided to start
production of their own batteries and
opted for a small 24 kilowatt hour of
battery giving it a range of just over
100 kilometers suitable for city driving
and that's about it but customers soon
realized that this paltry range was
dwindling quickly but just one to two
years of driving Dilys battery capacity
was dropping up to twenty seven point
five percent under normal use despite
careful in-house testing Nissan
overlooked some crucial test conditions
when developing their battery and
because of this they made some crucial
design errors to learn why this
degradation happens we first need to
understand how lithium-ion batteries
work a lithium-ion battery like all
batteries contains a positive electrode
the anode and a negative electrode the
cathode separated by an electrolyte
batteries power devices by transporting
positively charged ions between the
anode and cathode creating an electric
potential between the two sides of the
battery and forcing electrons to travel
through the device it is powering to
equalize the electric potential
critically this process is reversible
for lithium ion batteries as the lithium
ions are held loosely sitting in two
spaces in the a No
and cathodes crystal structure this is
called intercalation so when the
opposite electric potential is applied
to the battery it will force the lithium
ions to transport back across the
electrolyte bridge and lodge themselves
in the anode once again this process
determines a huge amount of the energy
storage capabilities of the battery
lithium is a fantastic material for
batteries with an atomic number of three
it is the third lightest element and the
lightest of the metals allowing its ions
to provide fantastic energy to weight
characteristics for an e battery but the
energy capacity of the battery is not
determined by this it is determined by
how many lithium ions can fit into these
spaces in the anode and cathode
for example the graphite anode requires
six carbon atoms to store a single
lithium ion to form this molecule this
gives a theoretical maximum battery
capacity of 372 milliamp hours per gram
silicon however can do better a single
silicon atom can bind 4.4 lithium ions
giving it a theoretical maximum battery
capacity of 4200 milliamp hours per gram
this seems great and can provide
increases in battery capacity but it
also comes with drawbacks as those 4.4
lithium ions lodging themselves into the
silicon crystal lattice causes a volume
expansion of 400% when charging from
empty to full this expansion creates
stress within the battery that damages
the anode material that will eventually
destroy the battery's capacity over
repeated cycles battery designers are
constantly looking for ways to maximize
this energy density of their batteries
while not sacrificing longevity of the
battery so what exactly is being damaged
in the batteries that causes them to
slowly wither away when researchers
began investigating what caused the
Nissan Leafs rapid battery degradation
they began by opening the battery and
unrolling the battery's contents they
found that the electrode coatings had
become coarse over their life clearly a
non-reversible reaction was occurring
within the cell but the change was
expected in fact the chemical process
that caused it is vital to the operation
of
battery when a battery is charged for
the very first time a chemical reaction
occurs at the electrolyte electrode
interface where electrons and ions
combine this causes the formation of a
new layer between the electrode and
electrolyte called the solid electrolyte
interface the name is exactly what it
suggests it's a layer formed by the
liquid electrolytes reacting with
electrons to form a solid layer
thankfully this layer is permeable to
ions but not electrons so it initially
forms a protective layer over the
electrode that allows ions to enter and
insert themselves via interpolation but
it is impermeable to electrons
preventing further reaction with the
electrolyte at least that's the idea
under normal conditions the problem is
under certain conditions this layer can
grow beyond just a thin layer of
protective coating and result in the
permanent lodgement of the lithium that
provides the battery with its energy
storage this process is not entirely
well understood and is outside the scope
of this video but we can identify some
of the factors that increase the rate of
this formation the expansion of the
silicon electrode battery we mentioned
earlier causes the fracture of the SEI
layer exposing fresh layers of electrode
to react with the electrolytes the
charging rate and temperature can also
accelerate the thickening of this layer
NASA performed their own in-depth study
of this effect and released a report in
2008 titled guidelines on lithium ion
battery use in space applications
sharing their findings the temperature
that the battery is charged and
discharged at plays a massive role in
the battery's performance lowering the
temperature lowers chemical activity but
this is a double-edged sword
lowering the chemical activity
negatively affects the battery's ability
to store energy which is why batteries
have lower ranges in cold countries but
lowering the chemical activity also
decreases the formation rate of that sei
layer this is one of the reasons the
Nissan Leaf battery lost a huge amount
of capacity over just two years in many
countries
Nessun performed most of its testing in
stable laboratory conditions not over a
range of possible temperatures
because of this they failed to realize
the disastrous effect temperature would
have on the life of the battery and
failed to include thermal management
system which is commonplace in anni
Tesla and this of course reduces the
energy density of the battery adding
tubing the glycol needed to exchange
heat along with the heat pumps and
valves needed to make a thermal
management system not only adds weight
but it draws energy from the battery to
operate boss it plays a vital part in
maintaining the performance of the
battery in essence choice to not include
a thermal management system even in the
2019 version make sitting poor choice
for anyone living in anything but a
temperate climate of course just cycling
the battery through its charged and
discharged states is one of the biggest
factors integrating the battery every
time you cycle the battery you are
giving the sei layer opportunities to
grow minimizing the number of times a
cell if cycled will increase its life
and maintaining an ideal charge and
discharge voltage of about 4 volts
minimizes any resistive heating that may
cause an increase in chemical activity
this is where Maxwell Technologies comes
into play Maxwell has two primary
technologies that Tesla will be taking
advantage of the first is what Maxwell
are known for their ultra capacitors
ultra capacitors serve the same
fundamental job as batteries to store
energy but they function in an entirely
different way and are used for entirely
different purposes the fundamental
difference between a capacitor and a
battery is that a battery stores energy
through chemical reactions as we saw for
lithium ion batteries earlier this is
done through insertion into the crystal
lattice capacitors instead store their
energy by ions clinging onto the surface
of the electrode this is a standard
ultracapacitor schematic on each side we
have an aluminium current collector with
thin graphite electrodes on each
separated by an electrolyte and an
insulating separator to prevent the
passage of electrons in an uncharged
State ions flows in the electrolytes
when a voltage is applied during
charging ions drift towards their
opposite charge and cling to the surface
holding the charge in place when a
device is connected
to the capacitor this charge can leave
quickly while the ions drift back into
the electrolytes the key limiting factor
for ultra capacitors is the surface area
available for this to happen and
nanotechnology has allowed for amazing
advances in the field this is what the
inside of an ultracapacitor looks like
it contains hundreds of layers of these
electron pairs but even with this
enormous surface area ultra capacitors
simply cannot compete with batteries
when it comes to energy density even
Maxwell's best ultra capacitors have an
energy density of just 7.4 watt hours
per kilogram while the best guess for
Tesla's current energy density is about
250 watt hours per kilogram counter to
what corporate-owned tech channels may
tell you ultra capacitors are not
intended to be a replacement for
batteries they are intended to work in
conjunction with batteries
ultracapacitor strength is their ability
to quickly charge and discharge without
being worn down this makes them a great
buffer to place between the motors and
the battery and their high discharge
rate will allow them to give surges of
electricity to the motors when rapid
acceleration is needed and allow them to
charge quickly when breaking saving the
battery from unnecessary cycles and
boosting its ability to quickly provide
current when needed for acceleration
this is going to be a massively
important technology for two upcoming
tesla vehicles the Tesla Roadster 2
which will boast an acceleration of 0 to
60 in just 1 point 9 seconds which a
normal battery would struggle to achieve
the discharge rate needed without
damaging itself the second vehicle is
the Tesla truck I have made a video in
the past noting that the Tesla truck is
going to be limited in its range and
cargo hauling ability as a result of the
heavy batteries it will need as trucks
are limited in waste to about 40 metric
tons in most countries this
ultracapacitor technology will boost its
ability to regain energy from braking
significantly and thus allows battery
capacity to decrease in turn allowing
the truck to swap batteries for cargo
the second technology maxwell has been
toting as their next big breakthrough is
dry coated batteries this is a
manufacturing advancement
that Maxwell claims will reduce the cost
of manufacturing a factor Tesla has been
working fervently to minimize with the
growth of the Giga factory so what are
dry coded batteries currently in order
to coat the current collectors with the
electrode material Tesla in partnership
with Panasonic's patented technology
must first dissolve the electrode
material in a solvent which is then
spread over the current collector both
are then passed through an oven for
drawing where the solvent evaporates
leaving just the electrode material
behind this adds cost to the
manufacturing procedure as the solvent
is lost in the process and the baking
process takes energy on top of this the
solvent is toxic so removing it from the
process would benefit the environment
Maxwell instead uses a binding agent and
a conductive agent which I assume will
work similarly to electrostatic painting
where a metal beam painted will be given
a negative charge while the paint will
be given a positive charge as it is
sprayed attracting it to the metal where
it will cling to it this painting
process also eliminates the solvents
needed in the paint in this paper
published by Maxwell technologies they
detail how their dry coating
manufacturing techniques could result in
a higher energy storage capacity of the
electrodes due to a denser and thicker
coating resulting in a potential
increase in battery capacity to 300 watt
hours per kilogram 20% up from our best
estimates of Tesla's current specs only
time will tell if this claim can be
realized at an industrial scale perhaps
more importantly to Tesla they now own
this manufacturing technique currently
panasonic owns the manufacturing process
for Tesla there is literally a line of
demarcation in the gigafactory
separating Panasonic and Tesla denoting
the point at which the ownership of
batteries transfers hands having to buy
their batteries from Panasonic adds cost
the Tesla will want to avoid in future
and this step could allow for full
vertical integration of their battery
manufacturing thereby making electronic
vehicles more affordable to the everyday
consumer all of this technology is
powered by incredibly smart engineers
working to solve really interesting
problems
and with so much focus on battery
technology across the entire tech
industry there's a high demand for
qualified engineers for anyone looking
to build or advance their engineering
career I highly recommend brilliant
brilliant recently introduced a new
feature called daily problems which will
present you with interesting scientific
and mathematical problems to test your
brain like this one that teaches you
about rolling resistance one of the ways
vehicles lose energy it takes you
through a short explanation of rolling
resistance giving you the framework you
need to rationalize a question they pose
to you here the answer is pretty simple
rolling resistance occurs from the loss
of energy to the ground and the wheels
so by driving from gravel to concrete we
lose less energy to the ground if you
answer a question wrong though you can
get help by discussing the solution with
thousands of other users allowing you to
learn from your mistakes brilliant even
have an app that you can download to
play these brain teasers on your morning
commute if you like the problem and want
to learn more there's a course quiz that
explores the same concept in greater
detail the daily problems are
thought-provoking challenges that will
lead you from curiosity to mastery one
day at a time so what are you waiting
for go to brilliant org ford slash real
engineering and finish your day a little
smarter and the first 500 of you to do
so will get 20% off the annual
subscription to view all problems in the
archives as always thanks for watching
and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
[Music]